in this video I now want to cover one of
the other most misunderstood ideas when
people think about taxes and that's the
idea of deductions so one of the most
common tax deductions is the deduction
you get on interest on your mortgage so
let's say that this year on my mortgage
of the part of my mortgage that is
interest let's say it's ten thousand
dollars it is ten thousand dollars on my
interest interest on interest on on my
mortgage and you'll either already know
or someone might tell you that this is
tax deductible and the misconception
that I've seen many many people times
that people think that since this is a
tax deduction that this ten thousand
dollars should be deducted from their
taxes so in the previous example we
showed this is the scenario where this
person making a hundred thousand dollars
would have to pay twenty one thousand
seven hundred and twenty in taxes and so
based on that misconception they would
say okay I get a ten thousand dollar tax
deduction now I would pay eleven
thousand seven hundred and twenty and
that is wrong the deduction doesn't
happen from the taxes you pay the
deduction happens from your stated
income so if I have if this person right
here had a ten thousand dollar tax
deduction instead of saying that they
made a hundred thousand dollars that
year they would say that they made
ninety thousand dollars they would say
that they made ninety thousand dollars
so once again the deduction does not
come from directly from the taxes that
would be a tax credit the deduction
comes from the reported income so what
would be the actual effect on the taxes
well we just have to look at this 90
thousand dollars it still kind of shows
up in that top bracket so the real
difference is just going to be this ten
thousand dollar difference before he was
paying this tip he was paying twenty
eight percent on this ten thousand
dollars now he won't have to pay twenty
eight percent on that incremental
$10,000 on this incremental ten thousand
dollars another way to think about it
instead of this being seventeen seven
17700 fifty times 28 percent it would
now be
7750 because the reported income is now
only ninety thousand dollars so the
actual number we can get our calculator
out and just calculate it there's two
ways you could do it you could just say
look if I'm going to have spend ten
thousand if my income is deducted by ten
thousand and I'm going to save twenty
eight percent on that ten thousand you
can just subtract two thousand eight
hundred from this but just to show you
how it'll all work then it all works out
to the same thing let's just go through
the same calculation again we have seven
thousand seven hundred fifty times 0.28
plus 48 thousand three hundred times
0.25 plus twenty-five thousand six
hundred times 0.15 plus eight hundred
and thirty-five dollars and it's 18
thousand nine hundred and twenty dollars
so now the taxes will be eighteen
thousand nine hundred and twenty dollars
and as you can see the difference
between the old and the new is exactly
twenty eight hundred dollars because
that's that's essentially what the
amount that we would be taxed on that
ten thousand dollars if we had made that
much money anyway hopefully that doesn't
confuse you too much